hey guys what is more important to you
this temporary world that is passing
away or
God I want you to answer this question
honestly while I explained the following
five things that all Christian men
should stop doing let's start with
number
one stop pursuing the wrong things you
could pursue a lot of things in life
money
relationships power but only one Pursuit
brings satisfaction on Earth because
only one Pursuit matters for eternity
becoming a true man of God I wrote that
on the back cover of my new book called
bold Pursuit a 90-day devotional for men
seeking the heart of
God I believe one of the worst things a
man can do is to waste his god-given
life to
pursue in his head the big things the
small things according to his three-b
brain because he thinks he knows better
than God to pursue that and to miss out
on what God has actually planned for him
and if you think that you know better
than God with your small brain then it's
extremely sad because you're missing out
on real purpose and fulfillment and
peace and God's blessing because if you
walk in your own way and not in God's
way in within his will then God's
blessing is not going to be on your
life Proverbs 3:5 says trust in the Lord
with all your heart and do not lean on
your own understanding in all your ways
acknowledge Him and He will make
straight your
paths
this is why so many men are complaining
and they say things like I don't
understand why God is not helping me in
this and maybe it's because you are
trying to force doors open that were
never meant to be open because that's
your will you're not following God's
will you're not going through the door
that he has actually planned for you and
keeping open for you that you need to go
through you see as a reborn Christian
you need to
abide in Christ and then you will
produce the right fruit John 15 :4 abide
in me and I in you as the branch cannot
bear fruit by itself unless it abides in
the vine neither can you unless you
abide in me you see that is what it
means to be a true child of God and if
you are a true Son of God then you don't
just think that God is some part of your
life now and then when you feel like it
he is your life now because he made you
a new creation he is the one that
directs your paths and you follow him
with your whole heart and soul do you do
that Galatians
2:20 I have been crucified with Christ
it is no longer I who live but Christ
who lives in me and the life I now live
in the flesh I live by faith in the Son
of God who loved me and gave himself for
me
are you a true son of the almighty
Living God you know sometimes we forget
who God is we don't have enough respect
for him we just take him for granted oh
my relationship with God and you kind of
bring him down to your level he is God
do you understand that in the Old
Testament only the high priest was
allowed to enter the holy of holies only
once a year but now after Jesus came
died on a cross Rose from the grave now
when when we accept him because of Grace
God Saves us he declares us as righteous
and that is why we can all enter the
holy of holies because that is now you
know there's no Temple anymore because
our bodies is the temple of God and we
can approach his throne with
confidence but with a lot of respect
because he is still God and he is Holy
when you live that way when you put God
first in everything everything that you
do suddenly everything else falls into
place everything you do is blessed
because you put God first and that is
the requirement for all his promises and
then when you start to do that when you
live this life of complete surrender
then you start to realize man now you
have everything you need you have
fulfillment you have purpose and you
have peace that surpasses all
understanding Jesus said in Matthew 16
vers 24 if anyone would come after me
let him deny himself and take up his
cross and follow
me that is the life of complete
surrender and the only life where you
will find true peace that surpasses all
understanding even when you're going
through trials and tribulations because
you understand because you abide in God
him in you you in him you can see the
bigger picture of life everything starts
to make sense and you move forward and
you can see how God is just blessing you
and you get the power to overcome any
kind of obstacle that this life throws
at you because now you're not tackling
these things alone anymore with only
your limited power mind capability three
PB small brain a lot of people think
they know better than God but now you
have the Holy Spirit in you the power of
God he is leading you and helping you he
is is in your corner fighting for you
let's move on to the next
one stop thinking you are always right
that kind of arrogant prideful hard
attitude does not fit in with the new
Christian
lifestyle that might have been part of
your old lifestyle the person you used
to be but remember you are a new
creation in Christ and now you are
humble you live according to the spirit
not according to that old sinful flesh
that's full of the ego and the eye me me
me sinful flesh there's a change because
you love God you also love other people
because that's the holy spirit in you
you know you've received that
unconditional sacrificial love from God
agape love and God's love for other
people flows through
you so then you start to understand man
you need to be the light of the world
you need to be a sweet smelling aroma so
it's more important to win the per
person that it is to win the argument in
the flesh full of Pride because you just
want to win the argument you keep on
fighting and you you want to be right
forgetting that you need to win the soul
of that person for Christ so you might
win the argument but you will lose the
person Proverbs
16:18 Pride goes before destruction and
a hearty spirit before a
fall
one of the ugliest things that you can
see is a self-professed Christian man
arguing quarreling with an unbeliever
for example about religious things but
he's doing it through the flesh full of
Pride full of ego because he wants to
win that conversation that argument and
he's not sharing the gospel taking the
lead of the holy spirit in truth and and
in love being humble Proverbs 11:2 when
pride comes then comes disgrace but with
the humble is
wisdom and Proverbs 16:5 says everyone
who is arrogant in heart is an
Abomination to the Lord be assured he
will not go
unpunished
you know there's a lot of people who
they just want to keep on fighting you
know they're like I'm right I'm right
I'm right and they will keep on
fighting because it is so important for
them to be right you know that is from
the sinful flesh and even when they are
right and the other person says okay
you're right they will they will keep on
going they will say things like yeah you
see you see you see I told you even when
things happen at the end they like I
told you this happened you don't need to
do that that that kind of attitude is
not part of the new life in
Christ examine yourself ask yourself and
be brutally honest do you think you're
always right will you argue with them
until they see things the way you do
because you think you're always
right if you are then you need to stop
living in sin because that is sin you
are quenching the Holy Spirit and you
need to obey God not just in the way in
in what you say but also in the way you
say things Romans
12:16 live in harmony with one another
do not be hoty but associate with the
lowly never be wise in your own
sight did you read that it says
sometimes be wise in your own sight no
it didn't say that did it say 50% of the
time be wise in your own sight no did it
say 1% of the time be wise in your own
sight no it says
never never never be wise in your own
sight no one likes people who think that
they are always right because they wre
of puffed up
Egos and it PE and it pushes people away
from the gospel God actually says in
Philippians 2:3 do nothing from selfish
ambition or conceit
but in humility count others more
significant than
yourselves Let each of you look not only
to his own interests but also to the
interests of
others if you truly love God with
everything that is in you you will also
love other people and you will care
about them you will try to understand
things from their perspective
you know the biggest challenge for every
reborn believer Christian is not other
people or the things in this world it is
the selflife
that is why Jesus said if you want to
follow him you need to deny yourself
pick up your cross and follow him pick
up your cross that means you need to
crucify yourself with Jesus that old
sinful flesh let's move on to the next
one
stop making excuses for your fleshly
nature Christian men do that a lot more
than they think for example some make
excuses or lie like the rest of the
world they get to work late and then
they say things like sorry I'm late it
was traffic well they actually have a
cup of coffee takeaway in their hand
meaning they took 10 to 20 minutes to
buy that coffee and also knowing that
everyone else in in a meeting had to sit
in the same traffic so it's just an
excuse that's not the reason why you're
late the reason you're late is because
you took some time to get that coffee
and also because you didn't plan ahead
you didn't wake up early enough another
excuse I sometimes hear at church at
Bible study is this I could not spend
time studying the Bible this week
because I was too busy because I was too
busy that's an excuse an excuse to try
and Rush Alize your sinful
Behavior you make time for that which is
a priority to you so if you didn't make
time for God that week it
means you took other things and put it
above God you made those things a
priority while God says you have to make
him your priority do you know most men
who say that they are Christians have
never read the entire
Bible they don't really make God their
priority prity and you know I've heard
this saying a lot you know in the
Christian Community God doesn't call the
equipped he equips the C but what they
don't understand is that is what the
Bible does the bible equips us so some
of them sit back and they want God to do
everything it is your
responsibility to grow with Christ to
read scripture to take time to spend
time with
God
all scripture is breathed out by God and
profitable for teaching for reproof for
correction and for training in
righteousness now listen to this that
the man of God may be complete equipped
for every good work the Bible equips you
for every good work but how will you be
equipped if you don't read the Bible you
can't and as men you know we are
normally only straight with one another
so let me be straight with you stop the
excuses spend time with God read your
Bible and then stop to be just a hearer
of the word and start to be a
doer because Jesus says if you love me
you will obey my Commandments and 2
Timothy 2:15 says do your best to
present yourself to God as one approved
a worker who has no need to be ashamed
rightly handling the word of
Truth nowhere does it say that only
preachers or pastors need to study the
word of God and know it it doesn't say
that at all they cannot live your
Christian life for you you have your own
relationship with God when you die you
alone will stand in front of God not
your pastor not your husband not your
wife not your children
no one in your family none of your
friends you alone you will have to give
account so let us stop making the same
kind of excuses like the rest of the
sinful world we are called to be set
apart we are ambassadors of Christ we
are in the world but we are not part of
the
world let's go on to the next
one stop saying vulgar words like the
rest of the sinful world you know I'm
shocked when I'm when I hear a someone
who said that they're a Christian and I
just hear o they speak these vulgar
words I feel the holy spirit in me ah
that pain and they continue the
conversation as if everything is
fine and they even use God's name in
vain having no respect for God God's
name would Jesus do that would Jesus
speak vulgar
words and you know I'm telling you these
things because I actually really care
about you because a lot of people out
there are sleeping they think that
they're
Christians but they're living like the
rest of mankind so they lukewarm or they
not Christian at all they think they are
but they'll get a big surprise at the
day of judgment and I don't want that to
happen to you
you I don't want you to be self
deceived Ephesians 4:29 says let no
corrupting talk come out of your mouths
but only such as is good for building up
as fits the occasion that it may give
Grace to those who hear you see true
Faith doesn't mean that you just
continue to live in sin and don't care
about it at all Paul wrote about this in
detail in Romans the rest of the New
Testament talks about it as well faith
without works is dead in James faith is
not like a jacket that you just
sometimes put on and take off when you
feel like
it you have been changed God himself
changed you he did a work of
regeneration and gave you the Holy
Spirit which means you have a whole new
spiritual nature within you and then if
you do send the Holy Spirit Will convict
you you'll feel bad about about it until
you can't take it anymore and you'll say
God please forgive me I'm sorry I don't
want to live the way I used to live
anymore if that
regeneration did not happen if you
didn't truly repent and accept Jesus
Christ as Lord and Savior it's not a
thing that you grow up as in a tradition
oh I'm just now Christian no you need to
be a reborn
Christian John 3 Jesus talks about in
detail if you didn't truly accept Jesus
Christ as Lord and savior and he came to
change you give you the Holy Spirit then
you are not a Christian even if you grew
up in a Christian home or go to church
or read your Bible sometimes 2
Corinthians 5:17 says therefore if
anyone is in Christ he is a new creation
the old has passed away behold the new
has
come people will be judged by every
careless word they
speak so with your new lifestyle it is
impossible to say the same kind of
things that you used to say vulgar words
bad words and even breaking people down
in the flesh you are supposed to be the
light of the
world Jesus said in Matthew 12 the good
person out of his good treasure brings
forth good and the evil person out of
his evil treasure brings forth evil I
tell you on the day of judgment people
will give account for every careless
word they speak for by your words you
will be justified and by your words you
will be
condemned if you truly are a Christian
man why would you want to tell dirty
jokes and speak vulgar words I ask you
again would Jesus do that Ephesians 5:4
let there be no filthiness nor foolish
talk nor crude joking which are out of
place but instead let there be
Thanksgiving how have you been living
your life
recently I'm just talking about vulgar
words but there might be other sin as
well how have you been living your life
recently be brutally honest with your
yourself this is important because if
you would die today how will God judge
you the reason you're still alive means
that God is still giving you a time of
Grace and every time you take that
breath it is a breath closer to your
death when that time of Grace is
done and then it is judgment and then
you will stand in front of God who is
Love Yes but he is also righteous
because he is
Holy let's move on to the next
one stop being lazy spiritual laziness
is sin Paul tells us in Romans 12:11 do
not be slothful in Zeal but fervent in
spirit serve the Lord this is a lot more
important important than you think and I
believe that we should preach about this
a lot more in
church let me read you something very
interesting from my book bold Pursuit a
90-day devotional for men seeking the
heart of
God day 48 someone once said the only
thing necessary for the Triumph of evil
is for good men to do nothing often the
reason good men do nothing is because of
spiritual apathy or
laziness this type of laziness or
slothfulness creates a vacuum for evil
to fill the Greek word translated as
laziness in the Bible is airia which
means the absence of care this kind of
laziness isn't caused by a lack of
physical energy it is a sinful condition
of the heart that causes people not to
care about anyone or anything the
consequences of laziness are dramatic
Proverbs 21:25 says the desire of the
lazy one puts him to death for his hands
refuse to
work spiritual laziness is especially
dangerous that's when we don't care
enough to read our Bible or go to church
or pray to our Heavenly Father the Bible
has an interesting command to those who
are lazy go to the an you lazy one
observe its ways and be wise which
having no chief officer or ruler
prepares its food in the summer and
gathers its provision in the Harvest
Proverbs 6:6 to8 in his own way the ant
understands that work is an investment
it diligently gathers food while it's
available and stores it away theand
understands that a time of Plenty is the
perfect time to prepare for a time of
need so it puts in the work to prepare
for winter when Provisions are scarce
and life is harder that's the reality
God wants us to understand spiritual
work is an investment making the effort
to study scripture go to church and
spend time daily in prayer has immediate
benefits of course but it also has
long-term benefits being grounded in
Scripture can help us resist Satan's
Temptations as he did for Jesus during
his temptation in the wilderness Matthew
4 vers1 to1 surrounding ourselves with a
network of fellow Believers can Inspire
us to live out our faith in bold and
impactful ways that's why Hebrews 10:
24-2 says let's consider how to
encourage one another in love and Good
Deeds not abandoning our own meeting to
together as is the habit of some people
but encouraging one another and all the
more as you see the day Drawing
Near staying in constant communication
with our heavenly father can help us
recognize his will for our life to enjoy
these spiritual benefits we must resist
the pull of laziness and stay
disciplined in every area of our
spiritual
life we must stay constantly aware that
the work we do now to understand
scripture build relationships with
fellow Believers and maintain an open
line of communication with God will pay
dividend for the rest of our life now at
the end of each Daily Devotional I ask
you to dig deep because we need to be
doers of the word and not just hearers
only so this is is time to examine
yourself and to be honest dig deep
laziness can seem like harmless
self-indulgence but that's what makes it
so dangerous in our walk with Christ we
confuse doing our own thing with doing
nothing ask yourself the following
questions and answer them
truthfully one how have you been lazy in
your spiritual
life two what what habits can you
develop to help you prevent laziness
from getting a
foothold take some time to answer these
questions honestly truthfully and if you
want to take a look at my book I'll add
all the information for you in the video
description down below now if you
haven't subscribed yet please do so we
have a lot of videos on the channel and
we bring out weekly videos so you might
be interested to watch one of these
playlists here and before you go always
remember life is short so please do not
waste
yours bye
guys